[MUSIC PLAYING]
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
Hello from I/O Live.
I'm Florina Muntenescu,
and I'm here with Ankit,
a product manager of Google Pay.
Hi, Ankit.
ANKIT PRASAD: Hi.
Thank you for having me.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
So what's Google Pay?
So Google Pay is
our payment solution
for both online and in-store.
Google has hundreds of
millions of credit cards
on file, from Chrome when
users autofill in Chrome
through Google Pay, when
users pay on the Google Store,
YouTube, Play.
We're bringing the power
of all of those cards
that we have to stores,
both in physical stores
and in online stores.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: OK.
So how about merchants
that have an Omni-Channel?
ANKIT PRASAD: Yeah.
So we do a variety of expenses.
So online, for
example, we allow you
to have a Google Pay button
that enables one-click check out
with any of these
credit cards on file.
In store, we allow you to
accept payments through NFC.
We have set up loyalty
these solutions so we
can help you enroll users
in your loyalty program,
make sure loyalty is conveyed
at the point of check out.
And then today we're
also announcing
like a good mobile wallet.
We're supporting
other items that users
have in their wallets, so
boarding passes, event tickets,
offers, that sort of thing.
If you are an
Omni-Channel merchant,
we're happy to work with you.
We enable at one of the demos
that we have today showcases
this very well.
We have an experience
that we built
with Oak Labs and DotDashPay.
It's a smart mirror.
You walk into the dressing
room with your items.
The mirrors will detect it.
We then enable a one-tap
check out with your phone.
Your loyalty is conveyed, as
is your payment credential.
And then after that, you're
rewarded with an online offer
that you can then use
on their online stores.
And so this is an example
of how we can bring users
back to the merchant after
having an in-store experience.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU:
OK, sounds great.
But I'm a developer.
So how do I get started with it?
ANKIT PRASAD: Yeah, we
provide a suite of APIs.
With just a few
lines of code, we
enable you to add a
Buy With Google Pay
button or a Google Pay
button for your website.
We also have APIs that allow
you to accept loyalty or allow
you to help get users enrolled
in your loyalty program.
And you can learn about
those at pay.google.com.
FLORINA MUNTENESCU: OK.
So check out pay.google.com and
get started with Google Pay.
Thank you, Ankit.
ANKIT PRASAD: Thank you.
I'm Florina from I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]